Joe Randazzo editor of the onion
um what did I think I would be doing
when I grew up it's funny I think I
always thought that I would wind up in
comedy somehow I guess I kind of
envisioned myself being like a bill
murray or somebody who was a my hero but
I didn't ever actively pursue comedy as
a career it just sort of like happened I
never really thought that I well I
always fantasized about it as a kid I
just for some reason it never seemed
like something that I should actually
really pursue so so I think I envisioned
myself being as much like Bill Murray as
I could and having kids and having a
cabin up in the woods somewhere and so
one of those things has happened so far
that's good
I think he was such a specific kind of
comedy that was sarcastic and confident
but also not cold and soulless you know
like not just doing comedy on the
surface level there was something really
endearing about him and you got the
sense that even though he made cynical
remarks that he was a kind of flawed a
normal guy as well you know I think he
just really sort of the standard bearer
for this tone of comedy that a lot of
people from my generation grew up with
you know Steve Martin was in there as
well Chevy Chase in those days we're all
I don't know if they're big influences
but I guess I haven't done a lot of
reflecting on whom I comedic influences
actually have been growing up with you
know two younger brothers and sarcastic
parents probably was the biggest
influence of any you know I don't think
anybody can really make me laugh you
know like my little brother Matt or my
dad or my brother Nick so I think that
had a lot to do with it
hard to be impartial it's hard to know
sometimes where the line is but I think
while we are a comedy outlet that's
first and foremost is is designed to
entertain it does really aid with the
verisimilitude of being a news
organization if you can appear to be as
impartial as a real news organization
tries to appear to be the main thing I
think is that nobody on the staff has a
political axe to grind or ideological
axes to grind I think people get more
upset about you know somebody having
finished the mayonnaise then they do
about genocide in Darfur and fortunately
but I try to be really aware of if we're
talking politically how many times we do
jokes about Republicans and how many
times we do jokes about Democrats and
sort of making sure that we're we are
walking down the middle a lot of that
work is is done for us just by the sheer
stupidity of politicians in general you
know we are really just trying to mock
things that are stupid and people acting
and stupid or hypocritical ways and that
happens on both sides of the aisle
enough more than enough but we always
get complaints from conservative readers
saying that we're not hitting Obama
specifically enough or enough but there
the problem is that people get upset
that we don't criticize policy
initiatives on the part of whoever's the
current president based upon what their
own perspective on that policy issue is
like weird we're not a left-wing
organization who has tried to propagate
a left-wing way of thinking and we're
not a right-wing organization is trying
to do that either so we can't pick apart
policy moves we just were not
politicians we're not political but when
Republicans for instance you know try to
portray Obama as
a socialist who wants to kill your
grandmother that's just absurd that
needs to be pointed out and ridiculed
because it's absurd and on the other
hand you know when Obama says he's going
to do one thing and then sort of backs
down and does another that also was
needs to be satirized so I try to be
very careful about it mainly because I
want both sides to read us and enjoy us
and we do have lots of conservative
readers who like us as well
I think them I think the much more
interesting thing for us to cover and
which is what we do well is to kind of
comment on what's going on in the
country rather than what specific
politicians are doing the these things
change from day to day and if you look
you know on a historical scale
politicians I've been doing the same
stupid things over and over again since
you know the time of togas so our job
and what we're interested in as
consumers in America in 2009 as
individuals and then translated into
what we do in the onion is is mocking
the media mocking Republicans mocking
Democrats I personally you know went
through a period a few years ago where I
was intensely consuming political news
and it wore me out and sort of depressed
me I read a lot less of it a lot I read
it a lot less closely nowadays than I
was say four or five years ago when
every new story would throw me into a
rage you know it was a lot of energy for
trying to go up against something that's
an immovable force that's been in motion
since the dawn of man you know man's
stupidity and hubris
no I think I think another one of the
onions strength or the reason that's
been able to do this so well for you
know 20 years is that we really try to
avoid thinking about will a reader like
this while at the same time not making
it to Insider E like that is definitely
something that comes up a lot that it's
either you know to sort of New York
centric or it's a meta joke that's
operating on all these different levels
that we understand because we're holding
ourselves up in this room for six hours
every week to talk through every little
detail of every little joke and the
reader doesn't care about that we have
to be we have to be aware of and
acknowledge that but at the same time a
big part of what we do is making each
other laugh in the room and some of the
you know best stories are ones that come
from a riff that takes place in the room
where a joke is brain is sort of
modified and through a third informal
brainstorm becomes a different kind of
joke you know that's stuff is always
really rewarding so we are extremely
insular in fact and and the language and
the language and structure of what we do
is really only known by a very small
group of people if you know what I mean
it's hard to explain to somebody how to
write an onion story
I think the method is pretty much the
same you know it's we've got it down to
a science man it's it's I think that the
number one rule is that the number one
thing that people wouldn't think of is
that if you're trying to be funny in
your headline it's not going to work
I've had people who are very big fans of
the onion and read it for years finally
hound me enough to be able to submit
headlines and I I've only agreed to do
this a few times but uh than they do in
the headlines have these sort of like
wacky a wacky element to them and the
thing about that you know the most
important thing I think to keep in mind
is that you have to we have to take
ourselves extremely seriously the
headline has to take itself extremely
seriously the character of the onion is
presupposing that it is the most
important media outlet in the world and
that it's word is essentially the Word
of God so everything that we publish has
to really feel kind of almost stoic and
over important and you know the
editor-in-chief before me Scott Dicker's
really taught me a lot about sort of
killing your darlings I guess i would
say where you cut out the part that's
funny from a joke it's counterintuitive
but it's that dry tone in that straight
tone of the newspaper article of the
kind of AP style of writing or New York
Times style of writing is what we strive
to achieve and sometimes just deleting
an extra little funny word makes the
joke that much better because it's
really emulating that style so that's
something that that's a that's really
important to what we do
well I'll I'll just go and totally
contradict myself right away because one
of my favorite articles was um I got
what America needs right here by Jimmy
Carter was an op-ed where Jimmy Carter
is basically talking like a like a New
York gangster so that's a kind of a
silly headline and we do do silly
headlines I mean we've had talking
monkeys and birds on the front page many
times but you know and there's we do
stories that are based on really local
small stuff you know the area man
stories and we do stories that are based
on big national events you know like one
of the most famous ones that pops into
mind because so many people talk about
it as having been prescient at the time
was right after George Bush got elected
for the first time it's um you know Bush
quote our long national nightmare of
peace and prosperity finally ends I
probably misquoting our most famous
article but you know it's just it's just
so straight and to the point and and
kind of powerful but I'm also a big fan
of you know we recently rayon one called
a grandma concerned about dinner roll
count you know for thanksgivings just a
small slice of life kind of story the
head has a little more of a literary
bent to it you know we can actually and
some of those kinds of stories bend the
rules a little bit and add some
flourishes and some pathos so it kind of
runs the gamut it's hard to say in that
respect what would be the ultimate onion
headline
everything you know comes from the
headlines and it takes a lot of practice
to kind of know which headline first of
all which headline works in the context
of the onion sometimes there are
headlines that come in that are very
funny but they just for some reason
wouldn't work they wouldn't they
wouldn't feel right and then after you
can get past that it's it takes a lot of
practice to figure out which headlines
have enough of an idea behind them that
they can be examined for 600 words you
know so the way it works is every Monday
we have you know our staff of writers
which is about 10 people and about 20
other contributors I'll submit a bunch
of headlines we go through the whole
list of you know several hundred of
these if two people vote on it makes it
to Tuesday and Tuesday meeting is the
big meeting where we actually select the
issue and brainstorm all the jokes so
that's when you get a lot of the
discussion this kind of almost
scientific discussion about what a joke
means is it is its target right does it
have enough legs to sustain a full story
and I think that's something that you
just really need to get with practice I
don't know that there's at least the way
my brain works there are other people on
staff who I think could actually explain
to you logistically how a headline how
you can know that a headline has enough
of an idea behind it to be turned into a
full story and that's kind of when that
happens and that's usually the most fun
part of my week is the brainstorming
session when you take this joke and sort
of move it around and play inside the
idea of it and kind of find out like
what kind of quotes would there be in
this story would the quotes be totally
are the quotes in on the joke as well or
is it one of these stories we're just
the onion it's just the onions
perspective on something and onion the
writer the reporter of the character of
the onion is totally missing that the
point you know we call that a misplaced
focus joke where we get really upset
about one little detail in an issue that
obviously you should be getting upset
about something else
see I even try to explain it i'm
confusing myself but that's you know
that's kind of it's the most grueling
part of the week but it's also the most
fun and most rewarding
yeah it does happen once in a while and
I apologize i'm trying to think of
actual examples it it happened for us in
a good way very recently we had come up
with this joke which i think originally
was AI NS deportes Lou Dobbs and then it
was supposed to run the next week and
then Lou Dobbs abruptly left CNN so we
actually we had this like perfect joke
that we had to do a little bit of you
know last-minute finagling and editing
and and photoshopping to get it out
right in time but we were able to
respond to Lou Dobbs leaving within an
hour you know on Facebook and Twitter
and places like that getting the story
out it was actually the first time that
we we did kind of breaking news and and
and you know because with with Twitter
we're able to reach almost 2 million
people instantaneously whereas it used
to be just a newspaper that came out
once a week in 10 cities now it's we can
really reach people a lot more quickly a
lot more people too so we did something
where we released that headline and then
just a portion of the story and the next
day re-released it again as a developing
story that now we've had the time to
write the whole article about so again
kind of really trying to mimic what it
is that actual news organizations do we
actually got some some inquiries from
different media writers about how did
the onion respond so quickly and onion
going to be doing breaking news now and
like no we're still just a stupid joke
factory we're not we're not gonna be
doing breaking news anytime soon
they're written by one person there have
been a couple such as smooth be who is
you know this kind of romantic lover
that have been written by multiple
people but the torch has been passed on
there's also a Jimmy in shower which is
written by a writer named Joe garden
he's the stoner whose cars forever
broken down Jean Teasdale who is
actually originally the onions humor
columnist but she's just kind of got
this this really depressing suburban
life in a loveless marriage but manages
to be chipper throughout it all and even
though she is apparently baron is still
written by a woman named Maria Schneider
who used to be a staff writer and editor
and left a couple years ago but we still
have her do that column these are so the
columns are so personal and specific
that it would be really hard for someone
to pick up and take over for someone
else after so many years of kind of
nuanced and layer and you know they're
often writing about things from their
own life that's translated into this
character so yeah
I think it informs a great deal you know
it's funny you can sort of pinpoint
sometimes in the meeting like oh so
obviously Seth you watched a lot of
Seinfeld over the weekend you know
because all the jokes are about Seinfeld
or TV commercials that you would find
during Seinfeld or if somebody's you
know especially frustrated with their
roommate like we have people in the past
we'll just sort of you can you can tell
through the headlines that are being
pitched you can sort of observe the arc
of their relationship with their
roommate and so I think because it's as
much these little minor things that
occur daily life more observational
stuff that makes it into the paper as it
is big national news events so
definitely people's biases about say
brunch or Aerosmith will make it into a
headline form and then get pitched at
the meeting and if it's if we think it's
you know sort of universally funny
enough it'll it'll actually make it into
the paper so there's definitely a lot of
that
we recently talked about actually the
idea just occurred to me to release like
the kornfeld papers or something that
you know some of his old writings that
had been unearthed but we decided to
kind of let it be for now you don't know
you never know it might happen at some
time but for us right now Herbert
kornfeld is dead still the victim of
white on white violence
I think it's been beneficial you know
it's sort of the thing about the onion
is it's despite kind of how a popular it
continues to become we still sort of
think of ourselves as outsiders you know
it was kind of founded on that idea a
very rooted in a very genex perspective
on the world of these slackers kind of
sitting around poking fun at everything
that was going on because of that I
think they're there is an inherent Gen X
/ slacker mentality at the core of what
the onion is so it's it's it's good that
we came to New York because it sort of
allowed us more exposure and we're more
in the heart of where the media is
happening and can just bring more sort
of interesting disparate people into the
onions sphere than you would have been
able to find perhaps in just Madison
Wisconsin to a great town but you know a
little bit smaller than New York so yeah
I mean it and it's it's a it's a strange
kind of almost paradox in a way because
we're satirizing The Onion's character
is this huge mega corporation that is
cold callous and uncaring and
unconcerned about anything but profit
like actively dislikes its readers will
sell itself out for you know for
anything but the integrity that we have
with the onion it's an actual operation
of the onion is exactly the opposite of
that we're we're we try really hard to
to be a little more conservative with
the kinds of ads that will allow to
allow on our site you know on our
website and in our paper I think we have
the standards that are as high as like
the Guardian in the UK i think is the
only one that when you look at the kinds
of AD models that we work with and what
we won't the only people with standards
as high as ours is the the Guardian you
know I've seen stuff on The New Yorker
and
or New York Magazine and New York Times
and you know that adds that will blow
you away there's you know this takeover
content and I don't want to promise
something that we can't deliver on
I think it's the same kind of stuff you
know where we rely on advertising and
advertising dollars have have just
really dried up I'm there's definitely
companies that we would love to take
money from but who are a little bit
afraid of the content you know we're not
afraid to put a big top story about a
pedophile on our front page and you know
a large corporation with with an image
and a brand to protect might be a little
bit hesitant to have itself be
associated with that in any way so that
i think is the thing that's specific to
comedy that that we face is our content
is is very r-rated and i think it
frightens off some advertisers but at
the same time uh I I don't think that
we've fared as badly as as lots of other
place we certainly haven't had to close
down you know lots of print
organizations have been just closing up
shop ad dollars are down but they're
down everywhere and I think if you look
at compare us to a lot of other
organizations we're doing pretty well
because we have I think a solid brand
that that people that readers have a
good association with and a lot of
companies want to be associated with
that and we have a lot of loyal readers
and and we we put out you know pretty
funny stuff every week so we haven't
seen them totally dry up but people
aren't shooting themselves in any
offices yet but we'll see
I think we're pretty comfortable I mean
I would like for everybody to you know a
million more people to buy our books and
know about us but I think there is a
sort of you know I never want to be
standing in my you know corner office
one stormy night with a glass of brandy
looking at my reflection and asking what
I've become dude the onion growing too
large so I think there is a there is
some somewhat of a fine itude I mean we
can never be Disney and we don't reach
the number of people that Jon Stewart or
Stephen Colbert can reach because we're
not broadcasting that way we're not on
TV so maybe some of these things can
change I mean I think it would be it
would be a terrible paradoxical shame if
the onion actually became a huge
heartless corporation that disdained its
readers but I guess you know the nature
of capitalism and the free market is
that a company wants to become as big as
it can so we'll just have to see what
happens maybe the onion will turn into a
monster I don't
stand-up comedy is definitely harder I
mean I like being onstage that's always
been you know fun for me better than a
like people ask like I know how do you
go up on stage I don't I don't think I
could ever do it and my answer is like
well I'm having trouble talking to you
right now it's not like it's it for some
reason some people just have it in their
genetic makeup that it's easier to go up
and interact with a group of strangers
than it is to have any kind of
meaningful interaction with with it with
a person whose eyes you have to look
into and I'm not saying that I'm a cold
heartless monster but a little sick but
still stand ups harder because it's just
you on your own the great thing about
the onion is it so collaborative you
know it's you almost kind of take on
this group mind there and people are
really willing to sacrifice their own
personal pet headlines or their own
preference on a joke for the for the
good of the of the onion for the good of
the the product I don't think either
that they that stand-up informs my work
at the onion very much or vice versa
because they're pretty different in
style the stand-up tends to be a little
more of a little more kind of do this
kind of character who that you know
exaggerated Saul of my own nervousness
and neurosis and they tend to be a
little more conceptual like as a eight
minute set then telling a joke and then
telling an unrelated joke and then
telling an unrelated joke I can't I sort
of can't write jokes that way personally
I have to think about how do I want this
this eight minutes to feel so that it
says awkward for the audience as
possible while also being funny and then
sort of right to that as opposed to this
is a good joke that I will expand on and
then find a segue into something else
for me I just can't it's really hard for
me to do that so one thing the onion has
sort of taught me though is how to
actually
right material and how to hit a joke as
hard as you possibly can relentlessly
until you know it's near to the point of
being too much so having that sense is
something that I've really gotten from
working at the onion you know over four
years but the two are actually pretty
pretty unrelated you know I do have a
website that I keep up as well it's
called the Joe Randazzo Association
which is now that I'm saying it it's
this sort of large heartless corporation
and it's the kind of goings-on at the
office you know messages from the from
the HR representative and schedule of
events for a seminar and what the lunch
menu is going to be and it's those kinds
of things so the writing for that has
definitely been influenced a lot by my
time at the onion just didn't how to how
to really write a joke but it's my own
personal stuff because sometimes you
just need to write your own personal
stuff as well
it's fun but it's also you know horrible
anybody who has to well I don't know if
anybody but when you have to sit down
and write something it's just the most
dreadful feeling in the world for me
anyway you know but it's also really fun
it's just you you forget when you're
having the fun you forget how how
dreadful it is and when you're in the
dreadful your forget how fun it can be
you know and you have to write something
in order to be able to have material to
perform and that's when the fun is so I
guess I sort of actually forced myself
to do it and I've listened to other
there's this great podcast I listened to
call discrete creative screenwriting
magazine where Jeff Goldsmith is his
name is senior editor at The Magazine I
think and he interviews different
screenwriters every week and he always
asks them if they what do they do to do
they get writer's block and do they what
do they do to get rid of it and every
time I'd like a hat I always have
writers but writer's block is the
default position for me it's like such
as struggle to get these ideas out so
they don't want to come out even though
they're in they're driving me crazy but
it's also just an incredible incredible
to be able to have a career out of
making people laugh and or a job anyway
I don't know if it's going to if it'll
be a career where you sit around in a
room and make people laugh and then put
together something that's so great that
you know I can be so proud of you know
when you see people on the street
reading the onion it's a really it's a
really wonderful feeling and I always
want to tell them you know I'm looking
the mastheads that's me I work there so
I'd say it's got to be that the fun
outweighs the the dreadfulness for sure
yeah but it's work you know it's work
I guess dead baby jokes are less funny
to me now that I have a living baby but
we still make them and still make them
you know I don't think anything is
should ever really be off-limits a
ticket to the your take on it it's your
angle on it what you have to say about
it that can be tasteful you know I don't
believe in things being too soon I just
think you know if you're making a joke
to sort of cash in on what everybody's
thinking and feeling and talking about
at that moment with no heart to it or no
thought to it or know kind of like human
empathy or understanding then you're
just kind of like a buffoon but you can
still make the joke you know I remember
when the balloon boy thing was happening
however I'm pretty active on Twitter and
there were this is at the time when I
actually thought that a you know six
year old boy was up in this balloon and
I just had this image of this kid with
like the wind rushing through his face
like screaming for his mom in the
balloon and it's like sort of made my my
gut wrench and people were making jokes
about it at that you know at the time
and I sort of got upset of people like
maybe let's wait and see if the kid is
alive before we make jokes about him but
that's the thing about this you know
being able to communicate with so many
people so quickly on Twitter it's like
it's a it's the the the time has just
compressed so much you know like a
Twitter our is like a year in real life
or something that's off the subject but
I don't consider anything any subject to
be taboo I think there's definitely
taste that comes into play and certainly
at the onion we don't you know there's
no there's nothing that we won't talk
about if we feel that we have a good
joke for it with a good angle
I would do this yes but i wouldn't put
her name in it per se and if you're
asking me to do it on the spot right now
i cannot it's a torturous affair to
write a headline takes many minutes of
torture sometimes hours and it would
just be humiliating to me and demeaning
to all of us for me to come up with a
headline on the spot for you today